love energy intense kill everybody
action it the whole bottom line was
ammonia what your action look like like
well guess what if you're actually
different every episode you're after
this is our Bible ooh our hero fights
like this he has these special moves use
a director creatively can do whatever
the hell you want but when it comes to
the action
it just has to stay roughly within these
parameters this is a cream is for and I
get I'm just crying we're not allowed to
see the film this is yet because it's
kind of under wraps and it's being shot
in China drop but as soon as we can say
we're gonna let corridor digital no is
the previous for an undisclosed secret
movie with tons of action in it and you
guys will be the first note fusing the
director is can we say the director is
John Woo
Godfather of action
minami just what we're doing as Angelus
we've got an action sequence and her
character is got a specific fighting
style so we're just sort of filling in
the blanks in terms of what her fighting
style is a safety remember to kick carry
kick them hard why does the game have to
be right there the guy has to be right
there because this is so complicated
when the person loses the gun the next
bad guy has to have a gun so that guy
again it's gotta have a gun platform so
that guy number four actually
mysteriously winds up having a gun
otherwise just pointing his finger just
doesn't work now if I do it fine if you
want to cool it on the horns so what's
it like working with John Luke amazing
he's a master
he's just the Godfather of action he's
just it's just it's a whole different
level watching him working so it does he
just have a very clear idea but he
what he needs he knows when he wants
he's already editing instead he'll
change things three shots and make it
better
like when you're in the middle of
shooting you're just sitting there going
this is you know God's like epic I train
Angeles whoo
I've been working with it for a while
she's getting really gnarly and super
tough now people so she had his
character in this movie and now the
action is kind of doubled our works cut
out first I'm making a move clapping ah
designer it's not you don't lose the
knife keep the knife with you you kick
slice your face in the wall die
I know these guys because they called me
and asked me to come in and do some
action form I had a great time we did a
bunch of projects my favorite being
shadow mortal
awesome awesome fun time when it's Utah
you know these guys were really on top
of it we shot the crap out of it covered
every single angle made it epic and it
turned out Robbie on the flip just try
to come around
okay I'm saying why this is happening
yeah well here okay so flip up to full
power
it's good to be it's giving your heart
dorsey dough so that you don't get there
a little too early that's all I'm saying
right yes I want to have a definitive
end yes okay I will flip it right a
frame and that ends holding with white
was it didn't even you know it makes
contact ourselves yeah good are your
reaction with Lille's push boom so close
the punch on Nakamura need to be hard
and his kicked me yard maybe your hand
it'll do it every single time but
webbing your hand right there it'll do
it every single time because I just want
a nice little look good getting into
stunts is really really hard you have to
start when you're young and it's best if
you've been
something else a professional mountain
bike rider professional motocross
champion professional gymnast
professional martial artist anything
that you are either a competitor at a
champion at are amazing at you should
start there it's really hard to be Joe
Blow and start going into stunts because
it's like four times the amount of work
so if you haven't been like a super jock
or super athletic gymnast or any of
those things you got started in sooner
so if you're a 14 year old kid you want
to get into stunt work you got to start
at 14 and work your way up and so by the
time you're 18 years old you've been
training solid for four years you've got
a whole bunch of cool physical stuff
under your belt actors have to learn how
to do their own action but the problem
with actors is that that's why stunt
doubles exist as an actor you can learn
as much as you can to be able to perform
your own fights but when it comes time
to certain things being really dangerous
that's the job of the professional
stuntman to make sure that you don't get
out choosing to ease and that actors
don't get hurt
so my computer's a lost cause
we had to reformat the entire hard drive
however we were able to grab from the
files off of it so it's not that big of
a deal honestly I got with the spin on
here I kind of feel dirty
we're just any kind of sucks for
stability standpoint out here it's
pretty good but like look at this quick
access bar on the left here and quit
guys it's not one driver I can't remove
that I can't remove my Creative Cloud
files from the bar on the side I can't
customize it but if all the way to the
right side of the screen like you're
going to do a half screen boom now you
have the option of what's going to also
be on that screen with it
isn't that fancy I just want a clean
operating system that lets me control my
computer that really too much to ask for
she was gonna happen is Microsoft's new
every day on Windows 10 I guess stick
with it for a couple years been going to
continuously change it and update it and
just basically pull things out on review
so if you rely on it's just in the work
a certain way well that's going to
change in about two or three years
guaranteed as they constantly update it
because now is the living platform so
I'm kind of sad I kind of really liked
Windows seven everything worked
I learned a while ago that like if
something's working don't update it
screw updates there's zero reason update
if everything is working update to fix
things if you've got any problems well
then don't fix it I'll just say Ivan
used my computer in a couple days you
know Windows 10 is installed that's how
doesn't feel like my computer anymore
I'm kind of sad I'm honestly the more I
talk about the sadder I get it's no
longer part of my family I just have no
reason to use it anymore
- then McCool programs and have all my
cool desktop wallpapers he's gonna give
it away
I'm not gonna give it away the problem
when there's like an axe just sitting
around like we use it was I think you
leaving a steel axe with you guys you
guys like ruin the same what was it for
4G we tore down the wall with it look at
this nothing what you did is a leather
ah Jay I'm gonna do this to winning your
computer maybe we clean it off for you
maybe now I can clean it is fine dirty
land
Bren would love to help out with that
real quick hi-yah watch the footage you
might as well show me the employee oh no
this is the user this is the one who
look we can't show that's the
embarrassing one and waiting to do this
for so long
no that's the issue don't panic oh yes
that's the that's the one of America's
about it okay let me drive your
motorcycle drunk
we love the axe from we hate football
God wow they're so nice you know what's
fun is between say so much in creating
good history it's often quite always
fits alert you guys like I don't know
how your ex-con is dad delete the
footage Julian over here and then hang
on it I think what I'm gonna happen I
just picture this oh don't why I'm not
about it actually we don't think of that
what do you did it well I'm glad you got
a bunch of fun footage it's easy enough
to wipe it off that's what axes are
formed do you get it deserve an Oscar
quick every single day